son 18 meses de investigación plasmados
en más de 800 páginas que concluyen que
la causa central del ataque al Capitolio
del 6 de enero de 2021 fue un hombre el
expresidente Donald Trump parte de la
tragedia del seis de enero es la
conducta de quienes sabían que lo que
pasó estuvo profundamente mal y sin
embargo trataron de restarle importancia
a minimizarlo o defender a los
responsables el documento de Ocho
capítulos detalla los esfuerzos de Trump
para anular las elecciones de 2020 en
las que fue Derrotado y así bloquear la
transferencia de poder por ello el
comité ya había pedido a los fiscales
acusar al ex mandatario de cuatro
delitos incitación a la insurrección
obstrucción de un procedimiento oficial
del Congreso intento de fraude a Estados
Unidos y conspiración para presentar
falsos testimonios y en una serie de
recomendaciones piden al congreso
considerar la creación de un mecanismo
que evite que Trump pueda volver a
ocupar cargos públicos justo cuando el
expresidente se prepara para volver ser
candidato a la presidencia en 2024
ningún hombre que se comporte de esa
manera en ese momento puede volver a
ocupar un puesto de autoridad en nuestra
nación no es apto para ningún cargo El
documento se da en unos días tensos para
Trump se espera que pronto la cámara de
representantes publique sus
declaraciones de impuestos después de
haber intentado ocultarlas durante años